ora tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi non è che
quindi siamo tornati su happy meals e
non solo anche perché sto mettendo gli
occhiali ma danno l'aria di un filo
della madonna del flash 2 con nonno cia
che tra l'altro e non c'è che da un
pezzo che non lo vedo che cos'è sta roba
ragazzi che cosa cazzo succede è un ma è
un tipo di massaggio nuovo allo ragazzi
distendetevi è tranquillamente
lasciatevi accompagnare da un massaggio
shiatsu che vide vi rilasserà i nervi
madonna mia che fia ebbe ma sono il
miglior massaggiatore del mondo è
naturale che ci sia fila per fare i
massaggi da me lei signora rileva un po
nick mi nervosismo sulle tette quindi
vediamo di vita sano un po la faccenda
benissimo ragazzi beni alla sicurezza
per caso passare a fare un massaggio io
sono libero ve lo dico poi fate voi
all of the dead kick ass no ragazzi
stilista confermi che dopo che l ok ce
l'ho l'ho preso l'ho preso
non so neanche chi cazzo vuol dire cos'è
sta roba ragazzi non mi stupisce tanto
la palla che fa i massacri mavic altro
le flessioni che riesce a fare sta tizia
perché poi si sta inglobando un
quadratino cosa solo lei la madonna che
cazzo sei
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tanto il folletto secondo me sta
cercando di rimorchiare perché rimasto
appeso non sa ragazzi si è stati già
prende spinaci o cosa la mattina l'amica
c'è una forza che manco rambo iii media
il nome il nome mi fa gasare in una
maniera così siamo pari stronzo non si è
rotta in faccia la gente bastardo
buongiorno nonno tutto a posto lo so che
mi vuoi bene me lo dimostri sempre col
tuo affetto per olio dammi una cazzo di
martino non nel senso da me l'ha proprio
allora non hanno fatto vuol dire ogni
campo sei simpatico ma ogni tanto mi
stai sul culo in una maniera che non hai
idea a parte ecco ti sta banjo merda
prega ragazzetta sono argentini uk
togliti dalla mia cazzo di faccia subito
cioè era una giornata di merda in cui si
è messo gli occhi davanti a me non è
normale
guardali sua stanza non so come è
successo ma ci siamo liberati di luke e
questo è un bene maledizione è una cosa
eccolo lì perfetto sono noi che cosa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è tratto questo si è infilato una spada
del culo da solo mi mancava e privi di
ogni tanto quando queste cose mi chiedo
perché hanno fatto un livello 3 di b è
più visto mi sembra normale sta cosa
nostra da un attimo che devo riuscire a
fare cose epiche
guardalo li guarda e impara perché tu
non saprà mai fare un cazzo di ste cose
te lo dico già però ma perché amiamo
lato una gara più che da milan la mia
gamba la gamba la gamba e mi metti ma ok
99 per cento impossible willy che carne
aspettare queste stime non è willing già
che mi hanno sbagliato il 9 a [ __ ] è il
bomba ti va un po di shrek solo io e te
perfetto chiarissimi che si ce la posso
fare non solo perché non dare
soddisfazione alla bomba che mi ha fatto
il culo sì ma magari se ci arrivò con la
testa sul collo e meglio allora per
minati di port royal ora non è così
difficile ce la facciamo sempre
steve che cazzo dirsi sul vivo
me lo puoi buttare tutto come stai
facendo adesso tu sai come far godere un
uomo con il deb league che cosa diavolo
mi significa devo andare giù dalla
collina con i tavoli perfetto magari se
pensavo 280 kg in meno era meglio ma non
importa
madonna si no cazzo si sono rimasto
dentro non so come ecco perfetto
facciamo la cacca
come ho vinto che cazzo e successo
perche mi è entrato un palo nel culo ci
caliamo un secondo hard bop prossimo
allora amico mio tu non sai con chi stai
parlando stavolta ti perdona ok perfetto
non suscitare non ho fatto neanche il
salto bellissimo che è bene mi dicono
che ho vinto ragazzi il sito si è
drogato non è normale
come faccio a morire micron cosa cazzo
chi c'ha perfetto cazzo ok questa da
replay
[Musica]
e magari seste le parti voglio invece
che il podio era meglio ma le pizze sì
sì non so come ho vinto non me ne frega
un cazzo di schede box almeno questo un
po meglio che dovrebbe ti sei perché si
è svegliato male stamattina non perché
c'è una faccia che non è orrenda vai vai
così ma è così
ok l'espressione non gli è cambiata
quindi va bè o cazzo tipo hai perso la
faccia terza cosa che capita ne va bè
non fa niente dai può succedere amico
mia ti siamo tutti vicini o cazzo cazzo
di schifo era io non voglio commentare
che cos'è appena successo ma non importa
tra l'altro è bellissimo steve così ve
lo dico
ok guarda tra web e devo scrivere le
spalle a dio sono in uno sguardo trovo
io stavolta ce la devo schivare dammi la
mano donna noi non ci salveremo perché
io ti amo io ti amo infinitamente ok ma
che forse non così tanto jeff beck
geisha shutdown piazzoli cos'è lega che
cazzo ti odio
chi cazzo è sto tizio ragazzo è
bellissimo chi è che strage di steve
navigli scusato mi sono confuso madonna
che disastro festa rosa c'è una questo è
un killer ragazzi ho comandato un killer
per 15 secondi impossibile ma che bella
gita di famiglia tutto normale come le
belle coppiette alla fine da senti cara
io vorrei chiederle di sposarlo ma
volevo dirti che mi facevi schifo e
adesso possiamo andare a puzzare
[ __ ] però altro nome spiegato come
la morte
ok c'è una donna obesa che vuole
stuprarmi [ __ ] allora che oggi non
è giornata bene anche mondo ciò che
hanno saputo o pensi che si portano via
jori ragazzi al giorno del giudizio
errato perché mi hanno buttato giù
[ __ ] a forse non è poi così
semplice come pensavo sono bravo si è
portato via uk è già qualcosa di voi non
l'hanno fatto gli zombie ma chi sistemi
sembra che si stiano in gruppo andò a
vicenda perché questa sera su ok per
questa è la posizione sexy dai dai dai
cazzo dai cazzo togliti dal mio
dell'etanolo lido stronzo ragazzi è di
marca 3 vabbè dai però non è possibile
ragazzi stiamo perché si trascina col
collo sto tizio perché forse non ho
visto brano [ __ ] ecco la mia testa
è andata pò tante notti di togliatti dal
mio pene se non l'hai capito togliti
[ __ ] maestra o che cazzo eccolo qui
questo io mi aspettavo ragazzi alla
innanzitutto nella mia stanza non si
beve quindi fermo non ci si aggiustano i
capelli praia non peccato godo dietro va
a fan culo
eccolo di perfett perché c'è un folletto
che piscia nella mia stanza maledizione
non si portano gli hawks sporca mica
l'ho preso
minchia che mira il mis trend che cazzo
vuol dir nulla tra gli hawks revenge tu
devi andare a fare il cazzo di compiti
smettila devi toglierti che allora si
stronzo
ti porto lo stereo non si può fare un
cazzo questo è una donna è peggio di
goku è una cosa
mio dio apply to se vai
ok sono vivi per miracolo perché se ho
trovato le gambe ragazzi dobbiamo come
sto pedalando di che cosa brutta le t
bird pollio cos'è no va bene figata
questo regala questo questo è una figata
pazzesca fatevelo dire che devo fare
allora per mica sono arrivato già due di
un miracolo
ho parlato troppo presto e linee anche
neanche a farlo nei pvs possibile sto
cazzo di gioco guarda che non ci sono
anche a fare il primo porca put a ok il
primo l'ho fatto una canna madonna se mi
chiamano sapevo sono ancora sono pero
salvabile
ok ragazzi ce la fa ce l'ho fatta sono
tornato su non mi chiedete come dove
sono
cazzo cazzo cazzo ma come si passa in un
buco così sì sì sì ok ok
[Musica]
già sembra una mucca no macché
ma guarda che non ci voglio credere una
cosa che non ci fosse [ __ ] mi hai
rotto le palle o altro next finalmente
analizzare questo ti sembra un bowl
trovo perché quello based cayman importa
ragazzi [ __ ]
una cosa è dove sono finito non era un
bolt roma non importa ho vinto lo stesso
reid target che cazzo odio
dio mio che tramite money essere andato
in botta ragazzi ci sia addobbi cari
cosi si ma è inquietante sto cazzo di
livello spero che lui ecco già hanno
perso fatemi di provare che non l'ho
capito eccolo lì sì quella nata [ __ ]
questo pure ma non ci posso credere con
uno devo beccare 3 come faccia beccarne
3 che ne ho due
anzi forse non riscono a capri si riesca
sino ad aia di nomi far questo non mi
far questo allungarsi ma se i [ __ ]
ditemi voi se si può essere più
deficienti di così non è normale
ok se si prova a fare un paio di livelli
che mi avete fatto anche stavolta perché
da un secolo il primo livello favi spero
che ti piaccia ciao
va bene allora proviamo a farcela non lo
so ecco già partito malissimo perché non
dovevo scegliere il nonno ciacco ma io
lo farò lo stesso con lui
suo nonno forza e formaggio la possiamo
fare non è così impossibile forse sì ma
forse no ma perché dove andare verso le
asce è che sei stupido da iphone
sì sì bravo non uno che tattica che
tattica della minkia carica forse forse
con non c'è che non è il massimo pro con
steve maina gioia mai una cazzo di gioia
steve muynaq eccolo lì bravo ti sei
incorporato nella cia del sultanato di
tutto la cosa dal culo perché io non
faccio niente ai cazzo sti una gioia una
volta sì che a mezz'ora per farlo sta
cosa non è possibile ai ragazzi i
prossimi ti faccio nel prossimo episodio
comunque volevo dirvi che era da secoli
ormai che non giocavo a te più quindi
avevo perso la mangia che non c'è le
lenti meno dimenticato minchia mi pesava
la testa ragazzi direi che posso
concludere qui l'episodio è perché mi si
vedevano tre volte ecco perfetto non
stavo registrano a non importa vero che
vi sia piaciuto come al solito
l'episodio ragazzi è come al solito se
il video è piaciuto al suo documento mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e come
ogni video tratta nella descrizione
tenesse lavoristi di scrivetemi non ci
rivediamo nel prossimo vitobello ragazzi
[Musica]